Okay so we're going to do that.
And I want you to figure out what would
happen if we got all the way down to
step five and
A is let's say, the mother.
>> Okay.
>> So what would happen step five?
>> A gets the baby.
>> A pays B and B pays F.
So F is basically a penalty to B for
lying.
>> Right.
And A [LAUGH] is worth the penalty to A.
But it should be, well, it depends on
how much B sets the value of V for.
>> Right, so,
what would B set the value of V for?
What are the possibilities?
Okay, it could be like,
1 million dollars, right?
So that would definitely
discourage A from saying yes.
>> Okay, so I say you pick the million
dollars because you think a million
dollars is more than the value
of the baby to the real mother?
That the idea here?
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, I guess so.
>> Okay, so
some value of V greater than V real.
>> Okay.
>> Which for
the sake of this discussion,
let's say is 1 million dollars.
>> Okay, excellent.
>> So, I'm going to claim
that B would never do that.
>> B would never?
So the disincentive for B for
that is that A can be like,
you know what I can't afford
a baby at a million dollars.
It's more than the actual
value of my baby to me.
You get the baby, but you're going to
have to pay the million dollars.
>> Right, now, that's not just
something that could happen,
that's something that
would happen right?
>> Right.
>> Because we've tied
everything up in the value.
So if V Is bigger than V real, then we
get down here and ask is it your child?
A will say no because paying V for
the baby is more than
what the baby is worth.
And so B will get the baby,
but B will pay V.
What do we know about V?
V is bigger than V real, which
means it's also bigger than V fake.
>> Got it.
So okay, so we're assuming
that B has a value of B fake.
>> Right.
>> So-
>> Well in this case we're assuming
A was the real mother and B was not.
>> A was the real mother and B was not.
Yeah, yeah, that's right.
>> That's what I said, right?
So B has a value of V fake.
So then what value of V would B pick?
>> So, B shouldn't be willing,
I mean B doesn't want the baby for
more than V fake.
That's how much B values the baby.
And if B suggests a value of V or
announces a value of V in step 3,
that's bigger than V fake,
B might get, you know, B is at risk.
>> Right.
>> Right, if getting the baby and
overpaying for it.
>> Right, and
having to pay more of this.
>> Economists are weird.
But that's okay.
So that means that not only will B not
pick something bigger than V real,
V would not pick anything
bigger than V fake.
>> Yeah, and in fact,
in principle, B would rather pay
up to V fake to get the baby.
Anything less than that and if B doesn't
get the baby, B.'s going to be sad for
not having offered more.
So at the end of the day,
B's going to pick V fake as V.
Okay so if B picks V fake as B, then
what do we know is going to happen at
this question,
when A gets asked if it's your child?
A's going to say yes.
>> A is going to say yes.
>> Why?
>> Well because if the value that B
announced is V fake and A would have
regret for not getting the baby,
yeah, for not getting the baby, and
not bidding up to V real, no, bidding is
probably not the right word, but let's
go with it kind of suggesting it, or
being it, A would have been willing
to pay up to V real for the baby.
So A would be happy to pay V fake for
the baby.
>> because V fake's less than V real.
>> Yeah, so A will, in fact, say yes.
A will get the baby,
will pay less than the value for it.
And what happens to B?
>> What happens to be B?
B pays a nominal fine.
>> Right, but that's greater than 0.
>> So if they both thought this all
the way through, now we can unroll back
all the way to step 2 where B is asked,
is this your child?
Now B is saying, I could say no and
A gets the baby and I just walk away.
>> I get zero.
>> Or I could say yes and
I'm going to end up paying a fine.
>> Right.
>> But least A is going to have
to pay a lot of money, so ha.
>> But it's all built into
the value here,all right.
So that means that since B is never
going to be willing to assert a V
greater than V fake, which means that B
is never going to be able to make it so
expensive that the real
mother would say no,
B has no reason to ever let it get this
far, because B will pay something.
B will get minus F,
which is less than 0,
which means if we ever get to step 2,
B will bail and say no.
>> I see.